now I'm sorry that you have to begin by
disagreeing with his grace
um if you're going to be a serious
grown-up person and appear to defend the
Catholic church in public in front of an
educated and literate audience you
simply have to start by making a great
number of heartfelt apologies and
requests for contrition and forgiveness
now you might ask
you're fully entitled to ask brothers
and sisters who am I to say that
well in the Jubilee Millennium year of
2000
the Vatican spokesman Bishop Piero
Marini said
explaining the whole sermon of apology
given by his Holiness the Pope that was
supposed to cover the entire history of
the church in its Jubilee year
that our quote Bishop Marini directly
said given the number of sins we've
committed in the course of 20th
centuries reference to them must
necessarily be rather summery
when I think Bishop Mourinho had that
just about right I'll have to be summary
too but I think he said just about the
least of it his Holiness on that
occasion it was March the 12th 2000 if
you wish to look it up begged
forgiveness for among some other things
the Crusades
the Inquisition the persecution of the
Jewish people Injustice towards women
that's half the human race right there
and the forced conversion of indigenous
peoples especially in South America and
that followed
a whole series of preceding apologies or
apologies I would say of a Kind made by
the late Pope John Paul who
it troubles me not at all to say was a
very impressive and serious human being
um it followed no less than 94 94 count
them
uh public recognitions on his part of
appalling crime and error and cruelty
and stupidity and defenses to the free
intelligence ranging from I shall be
summary like Bishop mourinhi the African
slave trade apologized for in 1995.
uh the admission that Galileo was right
about the relationship between the Sun
and the Earth and other orbs which came
in 1992 one might add no I won't say
it's too easy to say better late than
never here I said it
to violence and torture legalized
torture torture was legalized and
institutionalized by the Roman pontiff
during The Counter Reformation that came
in 1995
and for silence during Hitler's final
solution or shower as well as in 1999
coming in just under the Millennium
Jubilee wire an apology for the burning
alive in the main square of Prague of
the great Czech Protestant Jan Huss
um since that big Fiesta of forgiveness
that began in uh well culmination I
might say in 2000
Fiesta forgiveness Fiesta of asking for
it
the papacy's also asked to be forgiven
for the sack of Constantinople and the
massacre of Byzantine Christianity in
April 1204 as part of The Fourth Crusade
the anathema on all Eastern Orthodox
Christians as unbelievers Heretics and
people dwelling outside the health of
the church was lifted only in 1964. I
call your attention to that
he also expressed sorrow about the
murder and forced conversion of Serbian
Orthodox Christians in the Balkans
during the second World War
and it doesn't end there there are
smaller but significant equally
significant of vowels of a very bad
conscience these have included uh regret
for the rape and the torture of Orphans
and other children in church-run schools
in almost every country on Earth from
Ireland to Australia
and I'm pleased to see that due
reconsideration is now being given and
May in fact have been given to the
hellish I choose the word carefully
doctrine of limbo
Sage Augustine's cruel and stupid
disposal problem solution to a
non-existent problem that is to say the
destination of the souls of unbaptized
children up until now Catholic parents
have been taught that's where they're
unbaptized children went a form of
torture that's sometimes worse than the
physical now it seems that this piece of
augustinian sadism is undergoing
reconsideration as well but remember
this is from a church that's on the
whole Canada
we still wait a more directed mission
for example I give some suggestions of
my own while we're at it I would like
them to take back the Concordia made
with Adolf Hitler the first treaty he
ever signed giving the church a monopoly
over education in Germany in exchange
for the dissolution of the Catholic
Center party to give the Nazi party a
clear run I'd apologize for the latter
unpacked with Mussolini myself also the
first treaty ever signed by that fascist
dictator I would also think I'd want to
reconsider the fact that father tizo
head of the Nazi puppet state in
Slovakia was a priest in early orders
that the Croatian fascist puppets State
the ustaceous state of anti-pavlich was
also operating Under full clerical
protection and disguise as was the
regime of General Franco and the
dictator Antonio
Salazar I'd also want I really think I
would beg forgiveness for this I don't
think the German church should have
asked Hitler's birthday to be celebrated
from the pulpit every year until he died
he's a very serious matters they're not
to be laughed off by references to the
occasional work of Catholic Charities
but I draw your attention not just to
the apologies ladies and gentlemen
but to the evasive and euphemistic form
that they take Joseph ratzinger the
current pope considered by some by
Catholics to the Vicar of Christ on
Earth
says of Indians of the Indians who are
massacred in the course of conversion in
Brazil after the apology had been made
to them
he said nonetheless it must be
remembered that before we came to
convert them they were silently awaiting
the arrival of the church I don't think
that's a very genuine kind of apology to
you in his comment one of the few he's
made on the institutionalization of rape
and torture and maltreatment of children
in Catholic institutions he has said
it's a very severe crisis which which
involves us you said in the following
in the need for applying to these
victims the most loving pastoral care
well I'm sorry they've already had that
and to say that this is the
responsibility laid upon you by the the
horrific admission that you've already
had to make is not accepting
responsibility in any adult sense
when I say child abuse was institutional
how dare I say so how can I prove it how
could I prove such a thing well I'll ask
the I'll ask his grace
where is Cardinal Bernard law now where
is he
where is the Cardinal Archbishop of
Boston whose resignation was indignantly
demanded finally by 50 members of the
church and by the whole laity of
Massachusetts
who also demotted his prosecution for
the promotion and protection and
covering up and apology for and defense
of uh people whose crimes against
children are too revolting to specify
and he's not in the jurisdiction of
Massachusetts now as perhaps you know
he's the Supreme Vicar of the Church of
Santa Maria Marjorie in Rome personally
appointed by the pope to that as well as
many other important cynicals and in
2005 this man a fugitive from Justice
and from and from complicity in the
filthiest crime that it's possible for a
human being to imagine was one of those
voting in conclave to decide who the
next Vicar of Christ on Earth will be
I don't know I think I think I'd like to
hear a bit more Shame about this I think
I'd like to see a bit more confrontation
with the with the with the reality of
the business
now this is a
a serious question as I've said and
Whitaker can very often rightly in my
opinion attacks the climate of moral
relativism and if anything goes that can
very well be the handmaiden of
post-modernist hedonistic culture I very
often I'm glad that she points these
things things out but the rape and
torture of children is not something to
be relativized it's not something to be
excused as a few bad priests it's
certainly not to be excused by the
hideously false claim made by some
Catholic conservatives that this
wouldn't have happened if queers hadn't
been allowed into the church
sorry to say that queered him in the
church is an old story too
and it's worse it's much worse than
pornography and it's much worse than bad
language on TV
and it's the crime that cries out for
punishment it's the thing that if we
were accused of on this side of the
house we would die rather than admit and
if we were guilty of it we'd kill
ourselves and it's the one thing the
church has decided to excuse itself for
under this papacy
the same euphemism comes in the term
some Christians that is used in all the
apologies about the Crusades the
inquisitions uh the anti-semitic
programs and all the rest of it it said
some Christians fell into error some
Christians allowed themselves to be to
be uh deceived in this way and to act
against the gospel well
anti-Semitism was preached as an
official doctrine of the church until
1964. do you think that might have
something to do with public opinion in
Austria and Bavaria and Poland and
Lithuania that the Jewish people were
accused collectively as a people of
deuside of the crime of the murder of
God in the figure of Jesus of Nazareth
and that that anathema on them was not
lifted until 64 well after
the perpetrators of the Holocaust had
stood trial in secular courts and been
rightly punished for their actions how
can this church say it has any moral
superiority it has difficulty catching
up to what Ordinary People regard as
common moral and ethical sense and it
still can't make itself apologize
properly and I'll tell you why
because and I'll quote again from the
encyclicals it is said of the Crusades
of the complicity with the Holocaust of
the political and diplomatic alliance
with fascism
of all of these things it is said well
violence was committed but I'll stress
this I'll underline it I'll quote
directly in the service of the truth
so how is an apology possible
how is any understanding or undertaking
or firm purpose of amendment to be
allowed when the original sin
so to say the Radix malorum the Fong's
at Oregon the problem in the first place
is the belief on the part of this church
that it does possess a truth that we
don't have and it does have a god-given
right
a warrant a Mandate of Heaven to tell
other people what to do not just in
their public but in their private lives
and until that has changed until that
fantastic and Sinister and non-founded
claim is changed these crimes will go on
repeating themselves being partially
denied partially admitted when it's too
late to do anything else and covered up
behind all these crimes and miseries is
the denial of what we on this side of
the house affirmed which is that the
only little candle of hope that our
species does possess are our poor bear
forked primate mammalian species of whom
you have two such Splendid examples on
this side of the house and not bad on
the other tonight
um is the is the unfettered intelligence
the method of free inquiry and
philosophy and in science and the the
refusal to admit that any one person can
tell you not to do that
it's the one thing I might say I think
is if not sacrosanct or sacred is shall
we say essential
and the church has always stood and
still stands against it now in the
little time remaining to me I'll just
propose a few more apologies that we
might hope to hear uh in the immediate
future because it will come a time when
the church WIll issue apologies and
explanations and half-baked appeals for
forgiveness for things it's still doing
the readmission as a bishop of Roger
Williamson a member of Marcel lefevre's
fanatical hysterical Breakaway sect
so-called Society of Saint Pius X Roger
Williamson found hiding in a reactionary
quasi-fascistic establishment in
Argentina has long been a believer that
I'll put this shortly that the Holocaust
did not occur but the Jews did Kill
Christ in other words in other words
genocide no deicide yes
he was quite rightly excommunicated some
years ago along with several other
members of his rap bag organization but
Joseph ratzik has invited him back in to
the communion because to him having this
man this liar this fraud This Racist in
the church is more important because
it's Church Unity than the things that
he said and done and continues to stand
for is this not a crying scandal
I think that there will be an apology
for what happened in Rwanda
the most Catholic country in Africa one
of the most Catholic countries in the
world
um where priests and nuns and Bishops
are on trial for inciting from their
pulpits and on the church's radio
stations and newspapers the massacre of
their brothers and sisters
and the papacy was silent on this
appalling occasion and everyone in
Rwanda knows it and there hasn't yet
been a properly written apology for that
disgrace
staying in Africa I think it will one
day be admitted with shame that it might
have been in error to say that aids is
bad as a disease very bad but not quite
as bad as condoms are bad or not as
immoral in the same way